welcome you all to this scrutiny
committee I'm pleased to see
all the faces rather than through a
computer it's much better isn't it
the meeting's been streamed live and
broadcast on YouTube
and so just be aware that that is the
case
um the first item on the agenda is
attendance and I have an apology from
councilor Barry winstanley and I know
that uh councilor Carter's
um has told me that he will have to
leave
um fairly early actually from from this
meeting because he's got another
engagement I don't know whether there's
any other apologies
apologies have also been received from
Council wetton and councilor Denise
Weston
thank you
right item two is the minutes of the
previous meeting can we agree them as a
true and correct record
yeah is everybody happy
okay
item three is Declarations of Interest
has anybody got a declaration of
interest in any of the items on the
agenda if you have can you just uh speak
just just through you can you ask the
officer I'm on the planning committee um
Alex I'm just wondering am I okay to
speak to the uh scrutinizing the
proposals around the Carrington relief
Road
um
just to be guided by you is there a
conflict there
[Music]
I think by you uh declaring it as an
interest
um we'll be okay on that you don't have
a financial or pecuniary interest at all
in the construction day
oh firmly declare that interesting yeah
yeah thank you thanks for that
substitute member on the planning
committee as well so I should declare
that
thank you uh yeah as uh this committee
won't be making a decision on the road
it's fine yeah we're we're not the
decision makers we're the scrutinizers
um okay uh item four questions from the
public
um I have received one
um and it's about an item on the agenda
uh and that is the green spaces I I
itchem feels
um interest
um and what it said is why is the
scrutiny committee been recommended to
propose to the executive that Trafford
continues to rely on existing green
spaces space protections instead of
moving forward with a scheme such as
fields in Trust
the thrust of these schemes is to
protect parks and green spaces from
changes in political will and planning
department influence to ensure these
well-loved public assets are not
developed on
and retained for future Generations
we urge that the scrutiny committee
reject the report's recommendations and
instead further investigate how to
ensure these parks and green spaces
space protections can be improved
and we would welcome an invitation to
participate in the process
um in accepting that
um there is a recommendation in the
scrutiny report but it's it's for our
views how to committee basically
um and I think you can ignore
that and we will determine what we will
determine so
um I think I think that's all I will say
on that the item is on tonight and uh
we'll be discussing it in full
and so with that
um I'll go on to item five
um sorry sorry do we get to hear who the
question is from they've obviously
offered oh sorry yeah I I should have
said that that's Andrew good go Google
uh exact member friends of Trafford
parks and green spaces
yeah I should have mentioned that sorry
thank you
okay
so come on to item five
uh Finance change program
Tom
good evening chair good evening everyone
um thank you for having us back at
scrutiny I think we'll be here for
several meetings over the uh over the
next couple of months as we go through
the budget process but today I'm
bringing you an update on the finance
and change program
um you have received in your agenda
packs quite a large PowerPoint
presentation I don't intend to speak to
every slide you'll be pleased to know
which I what I will be doing is pulling
out key points
um on on this item so that there's more
opportunities for questions afterwards
yeah yeah yeah I I think that's what
we're going to do with all of the uh
presentations that we have tonight as
short as possible because I think
questions
um you know will be asked by the members
and and I'm assuming that all the
members have read the report so yeah
just just make the highlights super well
there's like I could do two very short
words for the highlights but I'll
leverage a little bit more in terms of
the financial situation for the local
Authority and local authorities across
the country
um so you'll remember back in the
February we set our budget and at that
time we started to talk about the
concept of a finance and change board
the rationale for having that board in
place is because over the past um two
years we'd utilized a considerable
amount of reserves there was good
reasons for using those reserves however
as we know from what I've said
previously once they're gone they're
gone so we had to look at different ways
of doing things the other pressure that
we had is that over 170 million pounds
had been taken out of local government
budgets since 2010 which made looking at
uh
cuts and and and decisions in the way
that we traditionally done it a lot
harder so we had to look at things
differently which is where as part of
the budget plans for last well the the
budget paper last year we uh started the
finance and change process
and that process was bringing together
of officers and myself as a chair
um looking at different working scoping
exercises for different areas of the
council looking at ways that um that
that we can save money looking at ways
that that bounces off with delivering
our Frontline services and meeting our
corporate priorities the board itself
initially met in the spring in March we
decided what our terms of reference are
they are all laid out in the the
presentation there are different groups
um eye chair one Graham chairs the other
we've been working on key themes that we
wish to explore further scope our
potential savings and income generation
opportunities for the borough and it has
been
are largely a success
um given it was only started down back
in in February we have identified a
number of um a number of ideas that
we're pursuing
um to help with not just this coming
Year's budget but with future years
budget
um however at the same time we continue
to face pressures and so I just wanted
to um to talk briefly about the uh the
current pressures that we're facing
um which will impact on our budget
proposals for next year which again it's
a later meeting you'll get to discuss in
probe further
we all are aware of the inflation
pressures that um that that we face
those are through energy impacts we're
aware of the um that the pre the pay
pressures that we also face and that
means that for the next year we're
looking at a budget Gap that we have to
bridge over between 24 and 26 million
so if you think about all the budget
gaps that we've had over the past few
years that is another huge bridge for us
to try and uh to try and complete
um we've been working very hard in the
the background with the finance and
change program we've also been working
hard as an executive
um to to look to look at um ideas to to
to meet that uh that budget Gap
um the I there's some scoping
um ideas that uh that we're looking at
this is a paid sorry slide 80 and some
some areas there that we've been looking
at in terms of doing things differently
looking at ways of generating incomes
looking at ways of generating potential
savings that will all feed into to
Future budgets and we've also looking to
launch a lobbying Campaign which there
is a a leaflet that we're putting the
final line touches to that will be sent
to different um audiences so they might
be national government they might be
trade unions there might be other
um
directors um groups that uh that that
Council directors Council officers are
members of at a national level we're
looking at our audiences and and who to
uh to to lobby with that just setting
out the challenges that we face as a as
a local Authority
and just briefly in terms of the um in
terms of the discussions that we've had
so far you'll be aware that we're coming
up to um we're coming up to the the
publication of the draft budget we're
finalizing our current discussions
around what we as an executive wish to
present in late October there will then
be a chance for scrutiny to look over
the The Proposal so far I have to say
that we will be coming with a gap so
that the budget work will not be
complete at October there will be more
work required through October to the end
of the year
um pending the um pending the
information and the numbers that we'll
get back from the settlement and any
spending review and any other
governmental decision that's taken in
the meantime so very brief a bit all
over the place in terms of my
presentation but I hope you see that the
the work that the financial change board
has been doing since the spring
has contributed tremendously to helping
us meet future challenges as a council
but we also balance it off with the
shocks that we have external shocks that
we have such as the energy price
inflation and such as the um the the
wage pressures and other demographic
cost pressures that we continue to face
so we are we're pleased with the
progress we've made so far we finance
and change but we also acknowledge that
as ever local Authority budgets remain a
challenge that we we keep working on and
we will get to a place in February where
we will balance thank you
foreign
thank you very much for that short
presentation uh click clearly you know
that it's going to be another challenge
as the many challenges before that
um right any questions
yep counselor Carter
thank you and kind of first off by
thanking a Graham and his team and uh
Tom leading the execon lots of really
really difficult
um uh situation just a couple of
questions please within the deck I think
there's identified as one
proposal under consideration that could
save over half a million pounds are you
at Liberty to disclose what that is or
is that confidential and whilst you
think of the answer to that second
question within the overall
considerations are growing amount of
revenue generated through enforcement
is that being reviewed as one of the
revenue potentials I'm going to let
Graham take the first question but for
the second question yes we are certainly
looking at enforcement and how we grow
that there are different things with
some areas of enforcement we can't use
that to contribute towards the revenue
budget it has to go towards set number
of um of of items so
that but but we're aware that obviously
as a as a local community people are
getting endlessly annoyed at fly-tipping
incidents at issues with bad pocket and
anything that that requires extra
enforcement so we are as an executive in
deploy exploring how we we look at that
further and that is work that we're
continuing to do over the the Autumn
into the winter well let's I'll let
Graham take the first question
sorry Council Carter they are familiar
which which particular side is that and
I should know because I drafted them
um I I thought I could ask the question
without
um saying what slide it was on there's a
slide that says there's
n number of ones that are worth up to
whatever fifty thousand pounds then why
number of ones that are worth between
that and 500 000 pounds and then one
that is worth over 500 000 pounds so
it's somewhere in the deck
I read the question last night I didn't
think to write the slide number down
wow brilliant
I think at the moment it's it's probably
best like like councilor Ross just
indicated we're drafting the budget
report now for
October's executive and which will give
a full list of all the individual
savings within within that overall
number of 6.19 million that we've got
there I must say at this stage obviously
all the budget assumptions all the
savings the numbers that may appear in
the draft budget report won't exactly
match these numbers because it's still a
working working Feast at the moment but
I think it's probably better rather than
just to home in on some of the the
larger ones just wait while the budget
report comes out if that's okay
okay hold a breath
okay is there any other questions okay
Council actsford
yeah I just wanted a bit of
clarification really when it mentions
collaboration and working with others
and
examples of being ambitious and creating
sorry an ambitious and creating change
and doing things differently and I
wondered what kind of what you meant by
that and I was also interested in
have we had previous good results from
lobbying because it obviously could be
quite time consuming so I wondered if
there's any evidence of that actually
working thank you I think that they're
really good questions uh councilor
Oxford
um in terms of the first one
collaboration I know certainly from a
social care area we're looking at how we
um how we work together
um across different uh greater
Manchester authorities there are other
examples that haven't yet come to final
fruition but you know looking at shared
services legal teams stuff like that
that they're all being constantly
reviewed to to make sure that we get the
best out of the the raw resources we
have across greater Manchester so when
they get to a stage where we think we've
identified it it will work it is
something that we can bring to the the
council to to agree on we'll certainly
do that but there's a lot of discussions
happening behind the scenes between
different local authorities as to how we
use our resources better
um to to lessen pressures that we all
face in terms of the lobbying we've not
done it like this before as long as I've
been in this this role
um I think it is worth doing because we
are facing like all local well like most
local authorities we are facing that um
that Dreadful situation where demand
pressures keep growing and our funding
isn't where it should be it should you
know it isn't matching the the pressures
that we face as a local Authority so I
think it's worth it
um we will certainly review the
effectiveness of it but I'm Keen that we
tell a story to not just our counselors
but the members of the members of the
public just what pressure local
Authority budgets are under and all the
things that we'd like to deliver it's
becoming increasingly difficult without
the um it's sufficient funding in place
and that funding would have to come more
so from central government
I had another bit of my question was
which was about the doing things
differently being ambitious and I was
also going to ask whether Community
wealth building would be included under
that kind of remit
Community wealth building it's it's not
quite something that we've been
exploring but I'm happy to you know we
we we're open to all ideas and
suggestions anyway that delivers our
Frontline services and helps reduce cost
pressures on the council we are actively
looking at um obviously we started in
February there's a number of work
streams that are listed in the um in the
presentation that we've been looking at
but there will be scope to explore
further so if you have any if or if
security members have any ideas that
they wish to feed in that may help in
terms of the um the future functioning
of the council I know that Graham and
myself and executive team were all we're
all ears and eager to listen
okay yeah counselor Proctor
and thank you chair
um yeah I just wanted to say I think the
financial change program is a really
good idea it involves staff it gets them
you know committed to work trying to do
and then there must quite a lot of good
ideas although it each year go by it's
getting harder and harder as you're
already intimated
um my question was on the consultation
process
have you thought I know there's a number
of options and approaches being looked
at and you know the look of it's going
to be a very extensive program but it
does have the impact of kind of raising
expectations from people that they can
put down eight ideas and it's obviously
involve you know greater budget costs
have you thought about how you're going
to approach that going forward
thank you councilor Proctor um in terms
of your first points about the the stuff
ideas game actually that that has been
really quite successful the the the
pickup rate in terms of ideas that have
been taken on and will be considered is
is higher than I would have anticipated
so we've been really really pleased with
the um the ideas that stuff had come
have come forward with some of them we
were already on to but there's other
things that we're we're looking to
explore
um and and hopefully they'll they'll
lead to a um a saving on our um our cost
lines in terms of the consultation
um this will be
for the first time we we probably will
have to go out to consultation in a way
that we haven't done for a for a few
years and we'll be looking at a range of
um of options the key thing for me is it
has to be accessible so we have to get
to as many people as we possibly can and
also enable them to understand the
pressures we face
um consultation it'll be a lot clearer
once the draft budget is um is is
published what areas that will be we
would be looking at and what audience
will be will be going to but in terms of
the public consultation again there will
be and could be ideas that the public
share with us within the constraints of
the um the budget pressures that we have
that will then have time and opportunity
to explore and see if they can feed in
and contribute to the final budget in in
February
hello Council Walsh uh thanks chair
um I remember last year we we weren't
aware of what the government funding was
going to be so very very late in the day
the latest it's ever been
are you aware of what funding is going
to be available this year
again that's as well remember to
councilor Walsh um no
um we will wait until the end of the
year for the settlement we'll wait to
see if and when there's going to be a
statement if it's still on what
allocation
um do you look we'll be getting the
department for leveling up a housing and
communities what allocation we'll be
getting my concern is
twofold on the national perspective
first of all
the continued inflation pressures which
are going to eat away at every single
budget whether you're a household
whether you're a private company whether
you're public sector that's causing real
pressures and we see that in the news
every day the second thing is that we've
got a new government and we've got a new
government that's
suggesting that they're going to be
cutting a lot of tax I don't know what
that leaves in terms of putting money
into public services I hope that they do
because
it's just if if they don't then they're
mounting up cost pressures over the long
term which which doesn't help any anyone
but we have to wait and see what they do
we it's it's different to last time
because I can't yet read what this
government's going to do in terms of
supporting governmental departments
particularly the the local government
but I don't know Graeme if you want to
say anything
just to add to that I think we've had
promises during the year
um
a couple of notable ones being
when Michael Gove was secretary that he
would give us a two-year settlement
which would have been really good for
planning maybe not necessarily what we
would want given the financial
challenges the government will be under
but we've not heard anything since so we
don't know about that and we've also
been promised elements of Reform around
Local Government funding again not
forthcoming so I suspect
where we will be again later in December
is with a settlement that is broadly a
roll over settlement similar to what
we've had in the past similar
whether there's add-ons around inflation
we will have to wait and see but the
rumors are that there won't be add-ons
or inflation and it'll be
probably very similar to what we've got
[Music]
have you got another question yeah
thanks chair just thanks for that um
just thinking about consultant with the
public
do you think it's a good idea
to go as sooner as you can to the public
and and make them aware of the situation
when he's read out between 24 and 26
million pounds funding Gap that's a
that's a pretty sobering figure and you
know public need to know that and I I
think we could
I'd be pushing encouraging you to go
soon into the public than that bear in
mind you're not you're not aware of the
fine detail as it just indicated thank
you chairman thank you I completely
agree um as soon as we've published our
draft budget we're looking at a
Communications piece around there
um the lobbying leaflet which is uh
you'll you'll see a shot of in your
presentation there we're looking at a
resident friendly version so that that
residents can really get to understand
quite quickly the challenges that we
continue to face against the context of
austerity that we've had since 2010 so
it is a very sobering situation it
continues to be year right year in year
out very difficult to to balance this
the the budget when we go out in a
couple of weeks with our draft proposals
as an executive team in the background
we're going to have to do an awful lot
more work to make sure that we are going
to be balancing that budget in the New
Year in case the settlement that we get
and Other Things fall short of where we
where we should be so it's hard and we
will be making sure that residents
understand as much as possible the
challenges that the council face and
what we're trying to do to balance off
those financial challenges with
delivering Frontline services
okay councilor Goggins
Coggins thank you um yeah I have um
quite a few questions I'll perhaps throw
them all out and see see um see what six
um
for context I suppose for people people
who are watching this at home or
following the 25 million is out of last
year I think that we have a budget of
197 million is this something like that
because of course sometimes it's hard to
make sense of big numbers like 25
million
um on its own 190 is it yes
um and um I suppose one of the questions
is I know of course that this is
mostly a result of the national picture
and the decades are more of huge
underinvestment we've had as well as in
the more recent crises and I wonder how
we are comparing to peer authorities
obviously we've historically
um been an underfunded as obviously
anyway and so there's one question
um the Deep Dives and service redesigns
on the discretionary Services
um again I suppose for people following
a home where that you know people don't
know what our discretionary service is
so um I I don't know if we if is there a
quick overview into into what is
discretionary and What's the statutory
service and and the other thing I just
noted from the point of view again a lot
of this I'm thinking as we're all saying
that actually that there we hope that
there will be massive public interest in
this it's quite a lot of acronyms in
here that even after five years of
reading canceled documents I'm afraid I
didn't know what AST or Moscow were and
and I was also drawn of course to the
phrase worst case scenario which is
which is in there but without any
details so I didn't know if anyone would
like to fill us in on on what could be
in there and and just to throw out on
this scoping there are a few things
again that caused my eye off-site
document storage I was amazed that that
was figuring that that could be a large
enough number for it to figure in a
discussion of 35 million pounds so just
query about that
um a bit worried I suppose about the
preparation for adulthood and the Care
at home things in that there I suppose
about our most vulnerable residents and
the any changes to them you know we
really have to be awful cautious about
um and the mention of reviewing the
delivery model for parks and open spaces
so again uh wondering what that's about
please I'm so sorry there's quite a lot
of questions so feel free to to censor a
few um if necessary but no that's fine
I'll answer as many as I can at this
point some of them will be for the um
for the budget security process but in
terms of banding with peer authorities
most authorities are an incredibly
difficult and tight situation um what we
have done which grain can probably add
to shortly is is band together with some
of the least the most poorly funded
authorities to to act as additional
pressure on the government to have like
a spending floor in So that it's you
know if they brought us up to a a level
that um that the others other
authorities that are better off are at
then that would help as the immensely
but going to go into that in a bit more
clarity than I can um discretionary
services
we do do a lot of discretionary Services
um discretionary service correct me if
I'm wrong but we're looking at things
like libraries in that things like the
water side things like the music service
things that we all hold dear so you know
it's when we review them we're looking
at how best we deliver them um without
losing them
um as each year passes that becomes more
challenging but when you when you sit
back and look and I'm sure that um we
can for scrutiny probably get you a list
of what's uh discretionary and what's
non-discretionary in terms of council
services and that might actually help
for your budget security sessions having
that as a as to understand that
um there's a lot of discretionary in
there and we're keen as a council to
keep hold of it it's just a question of
how we do that and that's something that
we're working through at the moment
um completely agree with acronyms I did
look at this and think oh yeah no I we
should we should have put an appendix in
here and that is something that we we
will do in future and certainly before
the public who haven't accessed it
through the website to see it we we do
need to do that and I take that on board
worst case scenario the good news is
we're not there yet we're doing all this
work now to get us just so that when we
don't get that stage and that has
involved some discussions and some
discussions and decisions at exec stage
before we go out to the budget draft
budget consultation but no we I can talk
for all my colleagues on the executive
we're we're very keen to make sure that
we balance this budget and keep you know
keep let's say delivering the services
that we all hold dear and avoid getting
that to that situation that more and
more local authorities are beginning to
get to
where they have to bring in the
Commissioners we are determined and I am
determined that we will never ever get
near that we will continue to keep
ownership of our budgets here
um and in terms of parks and Open Spaces
that's one of the ideas
um
I would say hold hold fire on that for
the moment and um you know it but as and
when we're if we do have a paper if that
happens to be the case it will certainly
go through the process and be decided
and you know discussed and scrutinized
but
they're just ideas and here at the
moment and some of them will fly others
will not but we know anything that does
get to that stage we will bring forward
for you to to look at further
all right I think that finishes uh that
agenda item uh and and thanks very much
for your presentation and answering the
questions I think for the scrutiny
committee uh we're going to do what once
a draft budget is finalized and we will
be scrutinizing that
um in in a lot of detail
um and obviously there'll be a lot of
other stuff on on that paper when it
does come
um so can we now move on to item
uh six which is Carrington relief road
again I think we have to assume that all
the members have read this so if you if
you just want to highlight a few points
thanks chairman thank you for the
opportunity Williams yeah
um to meet with scrutiny this evening
um cognizant of the remarks you've just
made sure and also being aware of the
fact that scrutiny have previously
conducted work around the relief road
that
um I was not part of the process
um with Irene to my position being new
on the executive
um I won't speak at length to the
committee report because I considered
that it is quite transparent in its
overview of the approach that's been
taken to consultation to date however I
am very happy to be part of a discussion
this evening if members
um feel they would like to have one and
I will pass over to the director of
growth and Regulatory Services now to
provide you with a brief overview of the
key points in the report thank you chair
thank you chair thank you Council
Williams um yes so I will um try and
keep this brief but perhaps just to for
members assistance so
um you'll be familiar with with the uh
the the Carrington uh relief row project
um and there have been reports to this
committee beforehand
um but um particularly want to I I
suppose highlight the uh executive
report
um which provides the most recent I
suppose position on the scheme as a
whole so if anybody has any questions
about that that's the the the the place
to to look but in terms of the the very
um specific aspect of uh engagement and
consultation and and how that can be
best developed and how we can you know
most appropriately Reach people that's
the focus of the report
um and you'll see that the sort of next
steps that we need to go through uh with
the road are set out in in section three
and off the back of that we're preparing
a consultation and engagement strategy
um and what um that aims to do I suppose
is then scope and guide what we're going
to do in terms of of trying to um uh uh
best Reach people in the local area and
bearing in mind of course quite a you
know buried area but with also you know
particular circumstances notably
um you know areas such as as Partington
um uh with you know a wide
um you know variety of residents
um but also noting it's an area of
long-standing uh deprivation as well
um so we'll we'll devise that strategy
and and then really you can see the the
kind of main stages that the intention
is to go through and then set out in in
sections
um
uh five
um and uh six uh seven and eight so
um the you'll see a table there on page
seven which kind of shows that the kind
of process that we would be aiming to go
through
um from I suppose where we are now
through to
um uh the uh post uh planning
application period And I have to put a
big caveat in there that of course that
is subject to a decision that would be
made Elsewhere on the planning merits
but where it to be approved we need to
start thinking about
what happens subsequent to that so those
are the main stages
um and then particularly I think section
seven sets out a series of stakeholder
activities
um and and some detail there about you
know how we're intending to do that and
what you know who who we wish to be
involved and and the steps uh that we
intentionally go through
um and then
um there will be a period of formal
consultation linked to the planning
application because that's part of the
process but then after that we would aim
to disseminate the results and as I say
um really continue that process through
the lifetime of the project
um I think probably the only other thing
to note is that of course this
um doesn't happen in isolation that
there are other things that are taking
place at the same time so most notably
we've got the places for everyone uh
process which
um of which you know the the relief road
is is part of the picture of The Wider
development around uh Carrington but
that kind of runs its own course
um but there may well be consultations
in relation to that as that progresses
through again through its statutory
phases
um and I think probably the only other
couple of things to highlight are the
two appendices and you'll see there
um that the
um there's a list of kind of what's
being done to date in terms of
Engagement and consultation a summary of
that
um and then you'll see a bit of a
program at appendix 2.
so that hopefully gives you the flavor
of the report and obviously you'll see
the
um recommendation the opportunity for
the committee to comment further thank
you Chad
yeah so thank you for that uh
presentation clearly uh that the last
time that we met we did talk a lot about
the engagement and consultation and uh
and it does seem that
um you know that is good going through
the process
um as you're going through the stages in
terms of that consultation
um Council Oxford
um yeah I was just after some assurances
really
um I've noticed on page nine it says
stakeholders need to understand the key
messages around the environment
um and I just wondered how you're going
to marry the promoting the road with the
realities that there will never be
increased traffic increased hgv traffic
school employment traffic resulting in
um
increase
emissions carbon emissions and um
reduced quality of air so I just wonder
how you're going to marry those two
things I also wanted some assurances
about the company you're using proper
Consulting because I know there are
shortcomings in the previous
consultation and I'd like to know why
that particular company was chosen
I'm also
um wondering about
um that the consultation is before the
outcome of place for everyone because as
you said that that may impact on that so
I've got quite a lot here um the other
thing is about the environmental impact
statement I understand that that's not
going to be available yet is it that's
going to be coming after the
consultation because obviously that will
impact as well on on the issues and
finally I noticed there was a meeting
with the ward councilors but I think
it's more wides you know it's more
widespread than that's going to affect
other Wards as well and it would be good
to know that everybody's involved not
just that specific Ward thank you
thank you councilor in respect of the
environmental impact I'll defer to what
the director of
um regulatory services in growth can
um provide you with uh in terms of the
engagement process and also the company
that have been used today I'd be the
first to say that I have concerns around
um the level of participation with the
existing
um consultation that's been undertaken I
think you'll see in the appendix one
um between February and March 2021 over
10 000 individual pieces of mail sent to
Residents um in booklo St Martin's world
the response rate was poor counselor um
I think we hold our hands up and say
that
um however that said um You referred to
the meeting on the 29th of June um that
was held between myself and councilor
new in our capacity as booklet St
Martin's Ward councilors the the main
content of that was around how we can
increase participation with the
consultations that have happened today
I'm really concerned that
um
today that the range of views that have
been heard we're getting a lot of
responses from outside but close St
Martin's Ward whereas the residents that
are going to be most immediately
impacted are those people living in
Partington and Carrington so I'm
particularly Keen for us to try and
drive up
um the response rate to the consultation
for them residents in the immediate area
I think they have been willing to listen
to us when we've come up with
alternative suggestions
um around perhaps including schools
um councilor Patel's advised us
previously when she was doing
consultation on the design review in her
portfolio area there is willingness to
engage with us when we go out into the
community and people will speak to us on
the shopping Precinct so those sort of
insights have been fed back and I I feel
confident that that will be taken on
board but the other thing I would say is
I think there's been some learning for
us there's local Authority about how we
do undertake consultation I'm conscious
that counselor
um Thompson is in the room and she'll be
aware of the the work that was taken
around the low traffic neighborhood on
the Walton Road estate in Brooklyn the
participation made there was really high
and I think actually there's been some
learning there around how we can drive
up consultation and elected members are
key to that so I'm more than happy to go
door to door and I think one of the
things that I'd like to see us bake into
our consultation process more widely is
trying to get elected members on board
earlier in the process that they can be
meaningfully involved in in consultation
with residents
um I hope that that touches on where you
wanted to
um where you were what you were
questioning around the consultation
exercises today
um certainly there is a commitment that
um the environmental aspect will be
explored further with Community groups
uh I hope you take that Assurance but I
will defer on the technical points to uh
Mr Fisher thank you yeah thank you thank
you Council Williams and and yes
um the uh environmental statement is is
uh part of uh the planning application
that will accompany the planning
application so so what this uh I suppose
report primarily deals with is the role
of the council as a promoter of the road
of course the council will also
ultimately wear a different hat uh
acting as the planning Authority uh and
of course there will be consultation in
the usual way on the planning
application but the
um when that application is submitted by
um and of course the council will be the
applicant almost certainly
um
um it it the consultant team will be
preparing a whole Suite of documents in
one of those this will be the
environmental assessment
thank you yeah so I'm
just yeah it does seem that it is quite
difficult for this consultation to be
like objective but the planning will be
won't it if you like yeah because you're
promoting the road at the moment yes and
and of course it's not it's not at all
uncommon
um for the council to have its own
developments as you'll know and I and I
guess in in most unitary authorities the
planning Authority is also the highway
Authority so so this is a city I mean I
know it won't it perhaps not happen for
a while in Trafford but
um it's you know nationally this
scenario plays out in in other local
authorities and so we just have to be
very careful about the separation of
functions I suppose thank you for giving
me some clarification thank you
yeah cat counselor Goggins
Goggins thanks um yeah thank you um
cancer actor has covered a lot of the
ground I wanted to to discuss actually
and just on the um intro uh I know I I
bring this up regularly on the
implications at the front of the report
in carbon reduction it just talks about
all the wonderful carbon reduction we'll
get out of the active transport and but
these things they do say implications
they're not saying what are the benefits
and there's no indication here that
actually we know that roads bring an
increase in traffic and that this will
actually increase our emissions rather
than reduce them so just to play yet
again for those and things at the start
of the
um of each report that they need if it
says implications it needs to list the
implications not tell us what could be
construed as the benefits and ignoring
the um the downsides
um as I said to cancer we've covered a
lot of what I wanted to say and I think
in terms of consultation low take up I
mean we all know why that is we know
that people a feel that
these things are a done deal and that
actually their voices aren't taken
seriously and B that the consultations
um you know are technical quite dull
documents that nobody you know not many
people really want to spend a lot of
time filling in especially when they
feel like it won't have have an impact I
do think from our own experience in
ordering ham that during occupy cancers
can can really help to engage people and
but I'm sure there's more that can be
done to make them a bit more
readable and a bit more attractive to
fill in
um
um and finally I had some questions sent
from the um friends of Carrington Moss I
think a lot of them have been covered so
far but one of the questions they did
raise is whether the consultation will
um have a minimum of 12 weeks which they
said it was a government best practice
and they've highlighted some other
um consultations in the area about
Warburton and the places for everyone
and the high net pipeline that might
also be going on simultaneously so I
guess those people who are going to fill
it in might have a lot of consultation
work to do in a short time and I don't
know if there's a time period already a
lot of things
thank you and councilor Coggins um
in respect of the implications Overview
at the start of the report take on board
your remarks um you'll know that this is
a sort of new addition to our report
writing process might be a bit of
fine-tuning for us to do I suppose so I
I take that on board and certainly
that'll be fed back
um in respect of the remarks you've made
about consultation I agree I think there
is a role for us to try and maximize
participation by making the process as
accessible as possible
um Partington is a community that I
think you know at times has felt
overlooked and as a consequence
um having felt that down previously and
I'm not saying that that's a part of the
council but by other agencies other
organizations
um perhaps there is an element of
mistrust there and that's the onus is on
us to try and
remedy that what I would say is um
I am heartened by the experience in
Brooklyn's Ward
um because like off the top of my head I
don't have the exact figure but the
response rate to people who have only
consulted it was over 50
um so we need to hold on to the learning
that and and certainly I hope we can
drive up the participation
um in Partington and Carrington and a
little bit of so Western award
um in respect of the question from Venza
Carrington Moss friends of Carrington
muscle in regular contact with the
council
um on this issue so what we'll do is
we'll respond directly to them and we'll
also advise the scrutiny committee once
we've done so
um around the consultation time scale if
that's okay thank you
yeah
thank you chair I just wanted to ask us
the the question I know given that uh
the executive already determined what's
what the uh the
uh that's what the rules going to be I'm
just wondering with the consultation is
that what scope of influence will people
have in in
driving any change of any kind that
perhaps
you feel that has come across uh in
feedback I mean what influence was it is
it a case of people might think well
this is a consultation for the sake of a
consultation as opposed to perhaps being
able to have some influence in being
able to tweak it in whatever needs to be
done and thank you Council but I think
that's something that we need to be
conscious of when we're designing the
consultation that we're able to
communicate really clearly to Residents
what views are being sought and what
they can influence um I think you know
it speaks to the point that councilor
Coggins has made about making the
process accessible and keeping the
language perhaps
um as basic as it needs to be so
certainly when it comes to the design
element we we need to be explaining well
this is about what the road looks like
what features it will have around active
travel
um do you have views around
um vegetation in the area and along the
side of the road so we need to find a
way to communicate clearly I think we
will get that I don't know Mr Fisher
does anything you wanted to add
um yes I mean I think you know it
we we need to appreciate that there are
certain limitations to this because as
you say um the the kind of overall
parameters uh have been um decided
previously but but actually when it
comes to there's an awful lot that goes
into the design of a road
um and I'll just perhaps give one really
small example but
um you know if you've got existing
rights of way
you need to be able to accommodate those
within uh the the you know the the route
um um because otherwise you may have
Severance or things like that so what
happens to say just rights of way is a
whole big issue in itself
um and that's one that I'm sure lots of
local people will be interested in so
there will be a series of those uh
issues exactly like that which you know
will need to be decided and that and
that's really the purpose of the
consultation I suppose is to ensure that
when the final design is prepared it is
informed by the views of
um a variety of people and particularly
local people as well
okay
okay is there any other questions
um can I can I ask you through you um
the company that's doing the
consultation that was mentioned earlier
I think
um did we consider doing it ourselves
in-house
um the company that we're using are
um they're essentially subcontractors of
Amy so
um the uh the lingro project is being
undertaken by by Amy and I'm sure Mr
Morris will be able to give you more
details about the kind of our
arrangement with with Amy but but
obviously there are in-house Highway
expertise
um they've brought this company in
because they've done similar
consultation engagement uh with other
roads so so
um the their track record is if you like
is working particularly on
um Road or infrastructure projects which
kind of throw up their own type of
issues that need to be addressed so
that's why they're being used
I'd be interested in any information at
all from from Chris Morris about the
chair
in terms of uh in terms of our
contractual relationship with uh with
Amy when it comes to uh when it comes to
uh to a lot of design projects we have a
close relationship with them
um because they are are actually our
highways Authority within it
so we're so actually making sure or or
putting them uh putting them in the in
the front of that actually actually gets
quite a lot of um a lot of synergies and
savings with uh with basically making
sure that we're following the rules for
uh for ourselves and making sure that we
uh making sure that within the highways
boundaries of the of the consultation
that uh that we're actually we're
actually doing what uh we need to do to
look at to uh to make sure that we hit
we fight we follow the rules
from that point
um as Adrian said when we when we moved
to when we moved to a larger project
like this bearing in mind this is
um at the at that stage of design it is
uh it's uh there is a there's a a large
bit of expertise within Amy that can be
that can be used to can be used to do
that but we call off through the
contract that uh that allows us to get
to get value for money so uh So within
that it it makes sense to follow that
line
um but with a consultation it says
itself
um through quite a lot of meters over
that over the last year uh we went
through with them in terms of the
selection of the selection of that of
that consultation uh consultation Supply
so to try and get the year to try and
get a better uh a better outcome if you
like through this which is obviously a
very same very sensitive and huge
project for uh for Trafford
councilor Thompson
thank you
the the table at the end of the report
where it's um
identifies future engagement and
consultation events
I'm just wondering why friends of
Carrington moss and seem not to be
involved in it going going forwards and
I I don't know if I'm missing something
but
is there it should there be a section
for Ward councilors stakeholders and
residents to be to be on that list
somewhere am I missing that I think it
is only on the list on page eight
um
page 16 17.
um the main events have occurred to date
which include a briefing to the three
local Ward councilors a briefing to the
local interest groups known as friends
of Carrington most plus other local
stakeholders including Partington Parish
Council and Peak and the northern
footpath Society
a site walkover of the proposed
alignment with a similar group of local
stakeholders
um the key aspects of the strategy have
been developed and are set out in the
report and what follows that is we we
have recorded each of these activities
and you can confirm
an overall positive outcome and desire
for all those engaged to continue to
maintain interest and involvement in the
scheme so so it has are you referring to
um Pages 16 and 17.
yeah to be honest I think it's just no
beside because the dates haven't been
booked in as yet
um I've had every assurance that you
know there's going to be routine
meetings around and the consultation as
it progresses and before its launch so I
think it's just that they've not been
penciled in the diary yet thank you
that's great thank you okay thanks
right
um
just uh to two questions really that
that I have and and that is
um the the time scale for this may to go
to in May to go to planning committee it
seems rather a tight uh timetable that
um and the other thing is
um there's no mention of the finance in
this report so I don't know
what the latest is in terms of that
because clearly it wasn't
you know the full amount
um that that we had to develop this so
I'm just wondering how how that is going
in terms of 106 monies and all of that
yeah
um thank you chair Mr Fisher can
probably explain the uh time scale in
terms of the planning process in respect
of um The Current financial position
available the belief road I don't know
how would you be content if we provided
you with a written response so that I
wouldn't want to wing it this evening
thank you
and chair just didn't say um you've got
the program there on
um uh it's table two which is just at
the end of section three
um and um we've said spring summer
um uh and I I think it's more likely to
be
um in in in the summer and of course
depends when you define
um the end of summer
um so
um so yes it it will be likely to be uh
well into the
you know it'll be well into uh
um uh 23 24
um Financial year when we the
application is submitted I expect
I'll hand over to Adrian Fisher in a
minute's comment as well but just a few
introductory marks on this obviously as
you might recall uh this came about to
emotional council at that point it
wasn't in my portfolio as such it was
that's more strategy rather than the
maintenance I was doing which I Now
cover both uh so obviously uh I think we
all want to do the best for Parks uh I
think the pandemic demonstrated that our
parks and green spaces uh coming to
London I think everybody wants to see
and do the best of them certain as a
council but we we really want to work
with fence groups local communities to
actually enhance them in that sense of
it there but uh I think uh when you
through the report there's some pros and
cons and a lot of the proposals there in
that sense that well if you don't want
to see it improve them protect them we
also want to enhance them as well in
that sense we're under we've got through
some of them there but while some of
them may give some extra protection they
might they might also prevent some
difference in the enhancements now as
you might know uh some of you may know
uh one of my own local parks Victoria
Park we've recently uh they recently
built a cafe and a community room there
now which obviously the community really
values and it's really enhanced use of
the park and actually it's really really
working well I think the problem is of
course on any of the proposals at the
end of the fort there it's all sort of
proposals would not have been permitted
in that sense that they're not conducive
with a green space in that sense of it
so it's been really really difficult to
actually get something like that through
so whilst we want to protect them and
development we got to care for we don't
hamper ourselves and indeed friends who
might want to do that a little bit more
but what weather protection might
actually make it harder than to actually
do such improvements in that sense to it
so I think it's right that obviously we
are using uh fields and trust and the
like and that just recently uh but one
of the ones we're looking at is the uh
William Rose site you might know there
and we're looking at a fields and Trust
for that with the exception of the
buildings on the site because we
included the buildings it would severely
restrict how we can develop that site
there for the local community so so
whilst it can give some uh protection to
it it can also prevent us from doing
some more little bits to it so it's
about getting getting the protection
right now the Newport does mention
Liverpool but I think Liverpool's
completely in a different scenario as
well they've got under position as you
will see in the report there
whereas we've exhibition we've got all
sorts of sites and and each one of them
being different opportunities and
different challenges so we want to make
sure that we put the right sort of
protection in the right location there
and I think what's proposed there in
section five there that some
enhancements through there but we'll
give a good level of protection and but
it'll also actually enable us to move
forward with friends groups local
communities to actually maybe put in
those little extra bits of things that
that may be fantastic movies so we
actually want to actually see some the
use of things like fields in Trust on
the right sites and we have done there's
a number of sites including term Moss I
think monitor was that escape me at the
moment as well I think one of the part
uh one in the south of the Boston as
well but I think so we will continue to
use those but we need to look up on a
side-by-side basis to see what's the
best way to enhance protect them and
actually help to improve them along with
local communities there so I think we
all want to do the best and it's
actually doing the right thing there but
I think that's a careful that we don't
take things a little bit too far that
might actually prevent us doing that a
little bit extra thing I mean one of the
things I would have as well when I first
become an exact member uh and I took
over one of the parts that there was a
proposal for one of the parks there to
actually give a tiny little bit of a
dead space in one of the parks now but
we actually stopped that the previous
administration so it shows that the
wheel is there to actually do something
like that I was certainly not see
developments hitting some perhaps there
but we do want to see some changes and
improvements but only I think where they
can actually enhance them and we have to
make sure that we're working with
properly with the local community and
actually uh veterans groups actually get
those enhancements I'll leave it there
and see if I don't know if they do wants
to comment that
thank you just uh I suppose a couple of
things to to add really
um uh I'm sure members will have noted
the the table at 1.3 which probably just
gives an indication of the scale of the
the different
um types of open space that there are in
Trafford
um and as cancer has said that um we're
blessed with
um significant areas and quite a big
variety of open space which which does
contrast with the position in in
Liverpool and then in terms of the the
different types of of model
um I mean again you'll see just uh I
mean hopefully we've we've um described
them there but but broadly we know we
have the fields and Trust which is
um uh quite a long-standing charity
um which involves
um uh I mean really the name describes
it very well really um the dedication of
of land to to them and with that brings
you know protection
um and um uh the the sort of long-term
regulation of those spaces
um the land trust is is a much more
um recent uh um addition to this area it
has its roots in English Partnerships
and in some of the kind of colliery
restoration work that um that
organization used to undertake
generally has probably a broader range
of different open space features so you
can see the list there at 3.2 covers
quite quite a vibe in a variety of
different things but again broadly
similar type of model
um at the time in Great Village Green
um is probably the oldest of the lot
um absolutely uh as again as its name
suggests rooted in uh the ancient
protections of open space and common
land and and whilst that is
um uh Hazard with it you know
significant sort of protections it also
has major restrictions and so you know
you can for example uh if people are
wanting to hire out
playing fields or a football pitch or
football team you can't necessarily do
that on a uh on on a a town in Village
Green
um and then the um you'll see in section
five a variety of planning designations
um some of which will already apply
um but uh a few more that we can
um enhance and build Acro um upon uh
through the local plan so
um I suppose a reminder that the local
plan is at the stage when
um we'll be preparing uh a sort of final
draft
um next year so it's sort of well placed
if you like
um to take on board some of those
concerns so I hope that sort of sets out
the um the different options and also uh
the merits of each of them thank you
chair
foreign thank you um yeah and I know
councilor Jerome who um proposed the
motion that this has come from um isn't
able to be here tonight but was was very
interested in it and has sent some some
comments and stuff with me
um
just to take up a few things on um
Victoria Park of course had a building
on that side so in fact we could have
had protections around the rest of the
park but not the building the same as
his proposed in William Rowe and so it
wouldn't have I think stopped that
particular
um building taking place assuming we had
dealt with the same way as the limero
and one of the things that interested me
was um the places are being taken
forward CrossFit bridge I think turned
moss and William Rowe and I was
wondering the reporters in detail any
criteria for how those have been picked
is it because of their um
Community impact is it because of Any
ecological value what sounds to me like
a list of kind of political hot potatoes
and um and um it slightly worries me
that maybe
um political reasons are being used for
deciding which ones will become fields
and Trust rather than
um looking at which ones actually have
their most biodiversity impact and so on
and perhaps it's pure coincidence that
those are the ones that have um caused a
lot of political issues recently and
obviously this talks about the
protections the local plan can give but
it doesn't actually State whether they
will so presumably this is an
opportunity for friends and Parks groups
and the cancers to start lobbying I
suppose the local for the local plan to
include their parks and I need to
highlight here obviously the cow field
and alteringham which the council has
plans to sell off about one-third of and
build on and so this isn't you know a
far-off threat that could happen
somewhere else that you know one day
your local park might get built on this
is something that this council is
actually doing right race now here here
in Altrincham so um you know there
really is a need to have some sort of
protection and so I suppose I I I would
like to see that their local plan has a
protection for for all of our existing
Parks um we can always draw lines around
the buildings that's fine there might be
an old fallen down shed that we can turn
into a lovely cafe or a useful
um space but um I I think it's something
that's hugely valued and hugely
important and um that you know all the
protection we can give them especially
because the local plan isn't it's not
going to cost extra to put them in the
local plant in a sense that's our our
work that we're doing anyway
okay thank you
I'll handle this way on some parts of it
there uh I can't comment really well
some of the other sites obviously uh
they weren't directly in my portfolio so
although I have actually come across
them and I know in in each of those
particular cases they were individually
discussed I'm not sure what political
reason it refers to but because because
they weren't in the mainstream sites
like most of the main Parks they were
different to those so it's actually not
a park as such and it's not directly a
green space so we look at some of that
crossing bridge it's a sporting area
something like termos I suppose as well
so it's a lot of different reasons for
that uh uh everyone might be able to
come up on that one I think particularly
put in the local planet yes I think we'd
all look at those sorts of things and
that would obviously will include
extensive consultation with local people
uh absolutely so there's all sort of
things that we can actually do with the
enhancements that Adrian third in
section five there absolutely want to do
it but we still want to be
overprotective I mean whilst as a you
can try and get down some of the uh I
think I did indicate in my comments
earlier you can try and get around some
of them there's no guarantee that when
you apply to the Secretary of State in
one case or to the fields and Trust
number that will actually agree to it in
some of those cases there so it can
actually make it complicated and harder
to actually get through some Lee scheme
if you want to do enhancement so I think
we have to pick the I think it's about
picking the right protection for the
right site and I think in most cases say
the parts you'll put parts on side and
talk about the one-off sites like like
refer to across a bird one row Etc to a
moss they're actually different from the
mainstream ones so they need to look at
how we can develop them separately and
protect them whereas uh mostly there was
a have actually much more
straightforward and we want to work with
local communities to actually enhance
them so I thought the audience got any
particular comments on those why are
they all particularly chose in fact they
just say I come across conversations but
I I was involved in natural details
throughout the proposals in those thank
you
uh thank you cancer I said um no I think
it is I mean we'd be probably happy to
perhaps answer that in uh in in writing
if that would be helpful I mean I think
it is rooted in the
um I suppose the origins of those those
particular sites which um
um are not you know conventional Parks
or things like that there are sites that
have a a variety of activities
um but would be happy to
um answer that if that would be of
assistance I think on the
um local plan point I should stress that
um that that most definitely will be
um you know subject to uh the local plan
inspector agreeing but they would most
definitely be policies in there for the
protection of open space who can
absolutely be sort of assured of that
um I think the thing that
um on top of that you'll see the report
references
um a local greenspace designation which
is a kind of higher level and the
government guidance is that that doesn't
apply everywhere so that kind of apply
nice to you have to demonstrate a
particular sort of value to the
community so I'm no I'm sure there's no
such thing as an average Park but if you
see what I mean a a part that perhaps
um you know didn't maybe have some
special historical cultural significance
might not
um meet the criteria normally you have
to demonstrate why this is especially
valuable to the community so so again it
wouldn't apply everywhere but it could
apply to some of our Open Spaces I I
think those three that you've referred
to uh to most William Rowe and Crossfit
Bridge they were all subject to uh
having proposals uh for different usages
and I think the the drive was the the
local communities actually wanted more
protection so I think that is the reason
why
um you know these three
um you know they're looking at coming
into uh fields in trust and so I think
that is the basic reason and I think
um
what what the council has done through
the planning process is to protect our
uh parks and open spaces and I think
when the you know and we have used
obviously uh fields in trust and other
measures to to to preserve the parks in
in Trafford and I think you know
um that that is to be you know
congratulated upon really that there is
that
um certain protection
um within our open spaces and Parks
no you wanted to speak thank you chair I
think we're all
um
wanting to protect our spaces green
spaces whatever they may be and
particularly at times now we're becoming
highly urbanized and we've got pockets
of Green Space which are very finite and
we need to try and defend as much as
possible I I know Council Edge did
mentioned you know the fact that
sometimes developments have to have
certain
um
priorities in some situations uh I sort
of inferred that until it I know
sometimes you have to look I think that
you might have one or two houses that
are develop a development for say one or
two families or something that might
sacrifice a certain Green Space which
perhaps is used by
the the community you know there's
residents a lot more so is it how you
balance something that could be
sacrificed which is uh
it's a difficult one because I I think
we've got Open Spaces which are sort of
valuable and precious to us in in
certain places that uh and valuable to
the residents that I think need to be
try and protected and and this uh this
kind of defense this protection would
afford that uh as and when they come up
so uh I just make that point
um thanks chair just just thinking about
are we having a sort of carte blanche
rule that we won't have
um
feels in trust or whatever it is so we
so if you get a local community group of
a very
well able to and organize it you know
I'll declare an interest we've had the
previous item about about the budget if
we thought we could save money if if the
residents could run run the cheap run
the park cheap and look after it you
know then and I think we should
encourage him and Council rather is
going to answer me thank you
uh just thank you uh
yeah just in terms of uh
so they are suitable for all sites and
that's what we have to look at in that
sense of it we want to continue to use
Fields until something I did indicate
that oh not just fields and trust but
like little protections but we need to
look at them on a side-by-side basis to
see which site which sort of proposal
would benefit those sites uh as a
mainstream most Parts we've got proposal
I set out in five that'll do most of
them there and and we already talked to
an agent highlighter as well the Extra
Protection is blue for local plan and of
enhancements so that could actually
improve on our general Parts but it but
we need to have something as well that
uh on those fallbacks particularly on
those special sites that are one-offs
and a different I think uh yourself to
highlighters from the possible reasons
for that that they were proposed
alternative uses so and it's actually
getting something that actually can
relate with them that no I don't know
all the different sites around traffic I
think it says they've got something like
150 odd green spaces and Parks from
around there it's something like 90
parks and spaces and so there's a whole
variety of whole size of uh protection
so we won't do the best for each
particular one there was actually
we're certainly absolutely not ruling an
email just get in the right scheme in
the right park like willing we discussed
it we discussed the different
Alternatives there and and we come down
that field and Trust would benefit there
at that site best out of all's proposal
so it is certainly the options on on
one-off sites will be looked at an
individual basis and they'll always be
in conjunction with local community
because we know that the groups like
that are actually quite involved in so
we're not involve them in that process
as well and they'll actually be a and
we'll work with them see what's Best In
some cases they might want to put
something that that it might be uh some
proposals I think like Adrian says uh
like uh Village Green stages you know
Akins can also seriously restrict
actually have the local community could
actually use things as well so so you
have to care for actually how you put
these Protections in sometimes they've
offered good reasons you can understand
but sometimes they might prevent uh they
can imagine not be saying that local uh
Community can't actually use something
for like a football uh playing or rugby
or something like because Village Green
status stops it nobody wants to see that
I'm sure nobody ever want to see that
but it's actually so it's actually just
getting the right thing in there and
every site will be looked at definitely
in that sense whether or not in the in
the standard well it's not no such thing
as standard Park as such as highlighted
previously but I think you know you know
what I mean there in that sense that uh
it's also that we don't think of as a
normal parking now on local street is
something that's uh different in that
sense so yeah we'll look at each one
individual absolutely and we'll always
be engaging with local communities on it
[Music]
um yeah I think some of my questions
have already been answered but I was um
interesting about the cost things we and
I think the original we talked about
having this on the agenda we will
thinking about having a presentation for
Liverpool Council because I'm not
totally sure you know I'd like to
understand more about the the advantages
and the process of doing it and the
costings the other thing I was going to
ask about was in in 5.2
where with the local Green Space
designation it says it protects land
other than in very special circumstances
and when it doesn't undermine investment
in homes jobs and other essential
services so I kind of wanted some
clarification on on that as well thank
you
please
[Music]
uh yes uh um thanks councilor
um uh yeah so it it uh the local Green
Space designation
um operates actually
um it more or less replicates green belt
in the way it works and so you may be
familiar with Greenbelt that whilst
um generally it is a very high level of
restriction in terms of building you
know there are it's not absolute you
know so there are certain exceptions
um and you may be aware from you know
various uh examples around the borough
for where
um development does take place in in the
green belt
um but you know it is it is very
exceptional and the bar is very high
indeed so so I think it's just a uh put
down a market that it's it's not an
absolute prohibition but it is a a a
very high level of protection
yeah I forgot to actually uh Council
actually mention about the finances
there because I was going to comment on
that and then I got it slipped me while
I passed on to aging just comment that I
mean one of the things of course is that
if you see red food report there the
cost of actually doing something like
the shoes about considering putting all
them into fields of trust would actually
be a massive Financial cost at the
moment as well I think given the
financial situation outline back house
for us early it's whatever we'd want to
put resource into and something that
might not be necessary and do spend that
money actually in the Parks themselves
on other green spaces would be I think
I'm sure we're all right to see them
enhanced she's actually making best use
of resources and giving the best
protection so it's getting that
combination right I think as well thank
you yeah I'm just aware that I know
friends of David Hume park for example
are concerned about this and I think
it's just you know people are feeling
frightened about losing the parts and
the spaces so I suppose it's just people
seeking reassurance and and knowing that
we're doing everything we can to protect
our green areas thank you
thank you
um so right at the beginning in the
fields and trusts or summary it mentions
I just wondered if you could clarify it
mentions funding opportunities for our
fields and Trust so obviously this is a
centuries-old charity now with
presumably some endowment or something
what's the sort of payoff to it if
something is in a field of trust is
there an opportunity that this charity
provides some some funding we're
concerned about the huge outlay in our
own staff time to commit to pushing all
the legal work through
what's what's the payback what's is
there any Financial benefit in the long
run how long is that going to take
therefore is there some actual advantage
to doing this rather than just thinking
well we haven't got the uh the finances
right now it's on 1.7 it says funding
opportunities but I can't pick up
further
uh yeah thank you chair
um yeah the thing the reference is
really to the fact that rather than
um uh the the charity coming with
um you know a a a pot of funds
um in each case
um I think the charity is more of a case
that the fact that it's uh if you have
land that is in that status
um you're then in a position to apply
for various various other funding
streams if you say to me
um so it's not that they will come to
the table yeah I I know the way it's
written it implies they can sort of come
come along with a with a hefty purse but
um alas I don't think that's the case
I'm afraid
it opens up channels I think that's the
best way to view it absolutely yeah
thank you Jeff has just add something
else uh I dare say many people it will
actually already be aware where friends
groups exist and they're a charitable
organization they can actually apply for
more grants and so forth so that is a
benefit to that as well yeah that's
absolutely right yeah councilor Coggin
thank you if I can briefly just
um
we've heard two stories one is this is
demandled where it's been picked for
fields and trust and which I think it
leads to perhaps what cancer Walsh was
suggesting the worry that there are
certain places where we have very
empowered residents and lots of friends
of parks and they're actually able to do
that and then there's a worry about
whether
um
um other areas actually have really
important places but um people have just
too complicated lives to be able to add
this to their list of things to do and
and the alternative story we've also
heard is that there's a history to the
origins of of the places and it's just
coincidence that it's only now after all
these years when they have become
political hepatitis they've been
selected as appeals and justifications
but anyway I'm not going to bang on
about that and the motion did actually
the green Amendment to the motion did
actually ask to review the cost and
practicality this does pretty much
nothing about the course and so I I do
wonder if this is actually
um fulfilling the remit of the motion
and I can send it around you it's in the
um
September I think 21 agenda and
um no that's uh anyway
um it's it's there review the cost and
practicality was the remit and and as in
case expertise point out this really
doesn't say much about the cost at all
and also doesn't give any indication as
to next steps it's merely telling us
what the options are is not indicating
that anything at all will happen and
that any anywhere else in the few that
have been listed
um that have already had a decision made
so um so I suppose uh asking really as
to whether we will get more information
about the costs was a deadline in that
Amendment as well that mentioned January
21 23 and and as to whether any next
steps will happen at all thank you okay
I think uh there is a reference on
pay pay page five around uh this the
scale of the work that would need to be
done we don't have the officers to be
able to do it unless we've got the money
to pay those offices to do it in one
foul swoop and I think that is an issue
um and it's one that we have to bear in
mind I think as well
is there any other questions
no
right
I mean but
having seen the report
um I'm confident that we we we have
enough protection in terms of the
um the the the Open Spaces and the parks
um and I think
um the cost would be
great on us and I think in in terms of
the fact that we
particularly heard
um you know the finance situation of the
council
um I wouldn't want to be recommending
that we we we did this
um
and I you know
I can understand why people think they
they they would want to do it but
um I think on the point of
um you know people in different areas
will be able to push for things
um that they don't push in other areas
um but I think if if a piece of land
in any area I think there's there's
three counselors they they would be
pushing for for it not to be done and
um and I think we we recognize that
because that's part of our job to to
speak to our resident and so on and most
of us are you know
um belong to friends of parks as well
and I think uh if anybody was going to
jump on this and say well we want to put
such and such a thing on a piece of land
there'd be an absolute outcry so
you know I I'm
I think what we what we're at what we
are doing we're all ready working with
fields in trusts on
um we already have some of uh you know
our Open Spaces uh interest in feels
interest uh and more coming on stream
um and I think we we've got a
flexibility really uh with with all the
strums that we have to protect our open
spaces and parks that that we need and
you know I've been doing this for a long
long time in terms of being a counselor
and I think we we
have protect our open spaces and and our
Parks
um really really well
maybe in an Ideal World of
um you know lots of finance and we we
might look at it in a in a different
manner
I think I'd just like to reiterate that
I felt like I didn't have enough
information and I started my it's not
not so much a question of like should
all our Parks be this but what would be
the process if a particular
it was good to have some more
information available on the costumes in
the process and and how's councils we
could support a friends group to do that
thank you
for that that is the question that we we
we're asked to to identify really should
we put them all into trust and I don't
think we should I mean it's as simple as
that yeah Council for I can't I'm more
inclined towards being persuaded what
councilor Coggins is saying that there's
an element of unfairness because if we
can't afford to put all the fields into
all the green spaces and Fields of trust
why do certain ones which it may be
politically expedient get passed under
the radar if we can't do it for all of
them we shouldn't do it for any of them
because what we're doing is no
disadvantaging the three all but the
three that are on the list William Rowe
crossford
because they're not going to make the
cut so they are less protected
and the hurdle is higher for everywhere
else because they're not making the cup
here so it's it's we can't afford to do
it for everywhere but we are going to
push ahead with certain ones and they
become protected and then you've got
other areas that aren't protected but
we're now saying it's too expensive to
do I could make if if I was drawing that
list William Rowe wouldn't be on it but
simply wedge would because that's the
Hot Potato that geraldine's smiling now
about and I think that strikes me as
unfair
but
um it's not unfair because they are
protected
you know that that is the point and it's
protected through our planning processes
and and our plans our local plans and
our corporate plans
so it's already got protection but but
anyway you know I mean if we want to
take a vote we will take a vote but we
don't normally do that in this community
but
um
it's about getting the right protection
for each site and and they're not
mainstream sites where there's a and you
self indicated that they it was a
potential different type of change of
use so we actually need to put in the
protection that enables it to be
protected but also to be developed in a
way that the community can support that
and and with them being outside the
mainstream type of parks it's actually a
that's a super alternative and we will
continue to look at on many of those uh
one-off sites on an individual basis to
see uh how we best can do it you know
because I think uh you know I mean we're
not ruling any of them out and I think
certainly to say that should it should
be all or nothing I think that's wrong I
think she'll be able to sort of have the
options there where we think it's
suitable in that place thank future
yeah
yeah
just uh I think
um
with the
issue about the cost of doing these
things I'm not actually there's a scale
for the bigger the area the smaller area
that happens but uh
I'm just wondering how that um
would they say that local residents and
things like that how they would be able
to engage in
in the process I mean I understand what
you're saying in terms of the uh
considerations uh how they would then
look at individual situations where
they're trying to I think I think
basically if if there's a piece of
um land or park that's under threat and
the residents will come forward and so
will they so will the local councilors
so you know I can't say that there's a
an issue
yes
um just to say that um although you know
we might not I I I agree that we can't
assume that we can we can do this for
all our green spaces I think I would
appreciate some more information on the
costings and
um and also on the criteria and if the
criteria is for places that are on that
are not safe then I think kind of I
think a bit of clarity on that would be
really useful for us so we can look at
it again
that that that's fine you can just have
uh the costings of you know putting them
all into trust
um you know
we haven't got a figure but you can
guess what it is really because it's
it's mainly the staff
um but you know if we if we get the
figure we can discuss it again for the
next meeting
yeah okay yes it certainly will be
possible to um provide more detail
um and um and sorry were you saying that
you wanted it for the next meeting or is
that something we can circulate to the
members of the committee well I think it
could be circulated and then decided to
work whether we want to discuss it
you won't be able to agree a
recommendation virtually you need to
meet to do them
but we will need to do that yeah so at
some point because obviously you know
it's we we've been asked to look at this
from
um from the full Council so we we need
to make a recommendation
okay
right uh can I just get uh clarification
on that so that was uh the resolution
was that it'll come back to the next
meeting with the additional information
I think it'll be sent round and
um
and then I think
probably online discussion whether we
need to bring it back
okay
[Music]
right
um so we now move on
to
um item eight Ernst an active
neighborhood and we we do have a report
um
because
you're into it again
councilor Williams
thank you Chad um as Sean speak at
length to the reporter report before you
provides an overview to the background
around the urmston active neighborhood
active travel program as you'll see in
the report following a public
consultation a widespread program of
Highways infrastructure improvements
have been identified in order to improve
active travel Provisions in the m41 area
the report outlines seven key routes
across the entirety of the m41 area and
on page 9 of the report you can see that
different routes have been assessed and
rated under a complexity rating which in
part relates to how easily the
improvements can be delivered on the
site that assessment has informed the
phasing to the rollout of the program of
works as you can see in Pages nine and
ten of the report with that I will hand
over to Mr Morris and Mr Ford if there's
anything that they want to provide
before moving to a discussion of members
so thank you
thank you chair thank councilor Williams
um no there isn't there isn't actually a
lot more to uh more to add really
um within the report the report
um obviously this is
and this is a point in the in the
program of the uh the project where we
move from concept design to preliminary
design
um so uh sort of the consultation we
talked about uh consultations that uh
that hadn't hadn't actually engaged this
one did and uh and did rather
spectacularly
um to the to the tuner 3400 suggestions
within the within the area
um realistically what that what that uh
what that meant was that it was a very
widespread
um
set of comments from the public about
what they wanted to see within this area
what the report actually says is that is
that from from that 3 400 comments
there's 18.5 million pounds worth of
work that can be undertaken within the
urmston active neighborhood now fairly
obviously we do not have the of the
financial the finance from the mayor's
challenge fund and from and from tfgn to
carry that through and look at my
authority so what we've had to do as
councilor William said was to work was
to put it into Roots uh which Mark did
and there's a very colorful diagram in
there which which sets out how it
affects each part of vermstone as a as a
whole
sorry
I'm told
um so so within the uh So within that
there is a there's a good appreciation
for people I think that uh of uh the
comments have been kept for every part
of them what we've got to do is to
prioritize
um to do that we've uh we've gone
through the uh the prioritization of um
uh part on on page nine which was to to
allow us to look at the most buildable
to starter to start as quickly as we
possibly can because people want to see
results and uh and what's out there we
want to make a difference
so so we we have put a a suggestion of
roads to the local councilors
um those uh those roads are detailed
detailed on page 10 uh as a as a set of
um a set of suggestions that set of
suggestions was there based around the
the red armor green
um rating but also based around making
sure that we got the maximum amount of
coverage across all areas within uh
within
um the the active neighborhood uh going
forward to make sure that we tried to
touch everybody with uh with it with an
element of that work and obviously that
that involved an element of compromise
um in terms of the terms of that
um we have been in discussion with cfgn
they did have suggestions to do uh to do
certain areas
um we've taken that to the local
councilors uh obviously and we have
actually gone against it so we've got
we've gone to make sure that we've we've
got that coverage
in terms of uh in terms of uh questions
around the routes that we uh that we had
we had one from uh from councilor Carter
from Carter before which was around
could we substitute out and what would
happen
um if the if the roots uh The Roots
there either under shot in terms of
budget or currently uh currently
slightly under
I think as we've already heard in terms
of some of the finance reports
um inflation is a is a big issue at this
moment in time and we have put a risk
contingency within that within the uh
within the figures for this
we will review that risk contingency and
uh and should we we be able to uh to
actually up the amount of work then we
will go back to the council as they're
involved within uh within the active
neighborhood with a uh with uh
recommendations of or suggestions that
they can that they can pick from to uh
to get the to get the right amount of
work for that uh for that budget
in terms of uh in terms of going forward
then uh which is the last page there are
a group of stage Gates which we have to
pass through some of these are quite
onerous this is
um a lot of money uh that's uh that's
put through from uh from central
government and to reach those stage
Gates we have to look at whether it has
a proper strategic case whether it's got
an economic case a commercial case to
make sure it's viable
um the financial case and of course a
management case to make sure that we can
build it so so there are quite a lot of
Hoops that we have to go through to to
do this uh going from a go from a white
page white page project which is uh
which is where it started
um
at this moment at this moment in time
we're in a position where uh we're
looking to start the uh the preliminary
design in January 2023 once we've gone
through though once we've gone through
the uh those stage gates with um uh with
tfgm
not Soldier okay thanks for that Chris
um
can I just read out
um what councilor Carter wanted to say
but he he had to go in he's got another
engagement uh this evening but I know
that he's been very active in terms of
the
um ernstein active
um committee or whatever it's called
um
and what he's saying is
the initial approved budget available is
is stated as 6.5 million the four
proposed initial routes add up to a
spend of Circa 4 million pound including
the contingency
we could make changes
to the proposal which at least allows
one of the major proposals to be
included in this initial stage by
removing root d
from The Proposal and adding
major Phase 2 to the proposal this would
bring the proposed cost to just under
6.3 million pound which is below the
available initial budget
and
um clearly I think as you said Chris
that
um it wasn't agreed by the local
Council and I assume uh the vast
majority of people
um
purely on on the basis that
the the route run to the east of
Hermiston and not across the whole of
ernstein and this proposal would at
least begin to
You Know cover they
the areas that uh that most people would
want at this early stage obviously we
know that there's other stages as well
so
um I don't know what officers views are
in terms of that or or the executive
member views around that
thanks Jeff
um I think as I said before one of the
it's a challenging environment at this
moment in time with inflation where it
is
um what we wanted to do was to make sure
first first and foremost that we we made
sure it was fair for for everyone within
uh within elmstone that uh that
contributed to this because we got such
an overwhelming response really
um to make sure that we uh that um that
we stay within this we needs emphasizing
we're at concept design at this moment
in time not detailed design
um so moving from concept design to
detail design we we move into into
um a much more secure uh phase of
actually estimating the estimating the
cost for these
um as we do that and we and we move into
it if we are in a shortfall as I say we
will make sure that that comes back to
um because back to the uh the meeting to
be uh to be ratified on whatever on what
on what we can uh what we can add
it also needs to be said as well that
with 18.5 million pounds worth of
suggestions that uh this is the first
tranche of money that money that we get
through from uh from uh challenge fund
and what we will be doing is uh is
putting forward a case to make sure that
we complete all of the 18.5 million
pounds
through the life cycle of the project
obviously that won't be within the
within uh within the next uh next two
years but but realistically having had
that amount of response from uh from the
locality there's a there's a real desire
to uh to support a
um a really
um comprehensive
um active travel neighborhood enabled
into that area
um and therefore and therefore what we
what we want to make sure is that is
that if we can't prioritize things for
the first tranche that they're
prioritized for the second trunch and we
make sure and we make sure that we uh we
can proceed in a in a fashion that looks
at risk of uh delivery but also looks at
looks at the fairness across the area to
make sure everybody gets a slice
chap I think the funding mechanism for
this program of works is perhaps more
complicated than I think has been
communicated at times on the surface it
appears that traffic Council has been
given 20 million pounds to spend as it
sees fit that that's not the case you
know the the funding that is available
is released in stages that we have to
satisfy as the program of Works
progresses
um so my concern would be that in
tinkering around with um plans as they
are currently proposed at this stage we
might actually compromise the release of
6.5 million pounds
um and in the climate of inflation that
we're talking about at the moment that
could be quite dangerous to the project
actually being realized I think
um so just to provide a bit of clarity
around the funding mechanism thank you
yeah I mean for for my power I don't
know too much about it because it's not
even in ghost Hill so
um
you know this is purely on what counts
for Carter has said and I think he he
wanted
um it to be considered he was the one
who first raised it in scrutiny so it
thought that the active ernstein
um
process
um wasn't going fast enough at one time
so that's why I asked for it to come
here unfortunately he's not here so
yeah yeah thanks a lot of comments as uh
one of the important to do actually here
tonight
um yeah there's always been a lot of
frustration about the delays in the the
processes unless it's raised a lot of
expectations with the the public and um
my feeling that was generally in favor
of what the the plunger going for right
now I mean you know
the biggest problem I think we have is
with communication with the the
residents because the expectation across
m41 is that this is all going to happen
in one fellow swoop and it's not there's
no way that's going to happen so I think
the phase program what you've come up
with is probably that's what we're going
to have at the moment and
um but I think that's got to be really
commuting really well to the residents
to make sure that they're aware that
that isn't it they see you know some
work being done that isn't a complete
end of the whole scheme
because that's going to lead lead us to
a way there's going to be a lot of
resentment and a lot of people getting
on our backs apart from anything else so
I think that communication is is really
important but I do understand that you
know that money has to be spent
in that time and and some of the schemes
you have prioritize are really really
good schemes so
you know there may be some differences
opinion from you know what to it because
the country said there but um I
appreciate that it's got to move forward
no then I I think you're right there
councilor Potter in the capitalization
you've provided
um I think one of the things we
struggled with with the um student
active neighborhood is it was one of the
first big consultations that we
undertook around the active travel
networks we went quite big on it and we
had quite a lot of Engagement and
unfortunately
um quite a bit of time has elapsed
between now and then
um you'll know I think um I've committed
to having regular meetings with the m41
councilors I know you've participated in
them I hope you found them worthwhile in
understanding where we are and where
we're trying to get to
um in terms of delivering the project
those meetings will continue
um and I'm happy for you to communicate
the content of those meetings with your
residents I think that's an important
role for members there
um I don't know perhaps Mr Morris there
was more you wanted to add in terms of
timeline a rough timeline moving forward
so that that can be ahead thank you
and yes that's no problem counselor
um the in looking looking forward to uh
to to the next stage and I think
um be the first to admit there was there
were some delays delays on the
communication with communication wasn't
wasn't good we've made some changes
within uh with it within what we do what
we do to try and try and realize that
um looking at the uh looking at um at
where we are at the moment as I
mentioned
um starting preliminary design in
January 2023
again I will add the account the caveat
that there are several stage Gates that
we need to pass through within tfgm and
some of them are onerous and that's my
uh that's my that's my caveat within it
but what I think we've got in mind is
that we that we do start work in late
2023 so we've got uh so we've got
something on the ground for uh for
people for people to see and that's our
that's our timeline that we've uh that
we've that we've currently got
um there are outside pressures that uh
that we've got internally we've now got
the resource externally in terms of in
terms of those they have to meet the the
expectations of uh expectations of of um
of uh to FGM Etc so uh so that's my
that's my only caveat
it's not an easy process is it not quick
and easy process but that communication
has as things move and you know time
passes I think it's really important to
to keep well keep us and keep the
residents informed on
yeah thank you I'll be brief I
appreciate all the time he's given me
tonight
um I won't um suggest there are
political hop status here because I
don't have to suggest the report
actually says so there's two plans here
the first plan as far as I can tell is
110 Crossings and a major route and we
know it has at least 5K of um segregated
cycle routes I think the second plan has
something like maybe 60 Crossings it has
no major route and there's no details of
how long the segregated cycle routes are
um it's hard to and it's got no
cyclopsis as well I think as far as I
can tell it's hard to compare to it'd be
really great to have two maps
um but um I mean I'm quite bewildered as
to what what is going on here really
because I mean the tfgm proposal is
about
I guess the thing is why are we trying
to do this
um you know the point is to change the
way people are moving about the people
are doing a huge number of Journeys
under a mile long
um by car when we actually could make it
safe and easy for people to walk and
cycle and Scoot and use uh mobility
scooters and so on
um and just a really high impact in one
really dense area is obviously what tfgm
have suggested
um which makes sense when you look at on
the map it's strategic you can see how
it will change people's ways of moving
about and then other places will start
thinking we have that too and the plan B
that seems to have been picked after
disagreements between the counselors as
I read it on the thing is just just
sprawling blob of line here and a line
there and it seems completely unique I'd
be really interested to know if it meets
actually tfgm's criteria and it's got no
major route it seems to have far far
fewer Crossings
um so I I guess what what are we trying
to do here are we just trying to
appease the masses or we're actually
trying to change the way the people move
about I thought it was a former and I
taught the tfdm's criteria for funding
would assume the former as well
um I'll stop now
thank you for your comments councilor
respectfully you've not been privy to
the meetings that have been going on
with the m41 councilors so
um I won't go into the detail but I can
assure you that that there have been
robust conversations and tfgm have put
in an appropriate level of challenge
which I think is at times why this has
taken longer than we would ideally hope
for
um I don't fully agree with your
characterization that there's a lack of
strategic
um import into the proposals that have
been agreed by councilors
um and I I don't fully accept your
characterization of the area that tfgm
initially prioritize there's a huge
amount of infrastructure infrastructure
work that is in areas that I I don't
agree
um are
affected by significant traffic brushes
I mean and I think there's also a
concern that the people we want to see
benefit from this are local residence
a huge chunk of the army that tfgm had
initially prioritized there isn't much
in the way of residential development
um so that there is a account
surveilling logic to the sort of a
position that you've outlined and that
is what was discussed with the m41
counselors I don't know if it's default
if you had any additional comments you
wanted to add yeah just to echo on
conversations with tfgm uh we go sit
through a design review panel at every
stage and that is scrutiny across all
boards bus views it's uh technical
standards review and the quite you know
difficult to pass and we have past this
stage so we're all compliant with all
local standards and the strategy was
initially developed based on the
consultation so all constraints and all
barriers for walking and getting around
they've all been taken into
consideration
thank you
thank you and the report says that um
one Trafford and have a meeting with
tfgm on Friday the 16th of the 9th this
year did that go ahead and we optimistic
with the going forwards with their
relationship
thank you for that yes we had the
meeting on Friday and we put across the
challenge that councilors wanted a
different route and they were agreed
with tfgm so we're progressing now
thank you
job done then
[Laughter]
um sorry to go have fun about this this
tfgm proposal councilor Coggins likes
that proposal but that really did slow
the whole thing down didn't it put a
Spanish I'm just thinking
how how that occurred you would have
thought is it did it be more chewing and
thrown before that initial plan came out
but appreciate you can't go into details
thank you
I don't think we need to do we because
um obviously that's in the past in a way
and I think what we're trying to do is
to move forward into the future
um and I I'm I'm not sure that this
committee can
sort of
um propose anything I don't know uh
clearly
um councilor Carter wanted us to raise
this I don't know whether it's helpful
or not helpful
um but you know I'm happy to pass it
over
um to to to to to to the officers and as
a proposal I don't know whether that
one's been considered directly or I
think this was originally propels wasn't
it because of the there seemed to be a
log Jam it was going nowhere yeah so I
think that's why it came to to this
committee
since we're moving
I'd be happy because I think sometimes
you've just got to get on with it I
think I think the one thing I would say
is that uh is that
um
in everybody's defense is that the
amount of spending on active travel
while not what some people would like is
unprecedented towards what we've seen
before
um and with the uh with the amount of
resource that we've put into it
um which at times needed to be faster
um I think tsgm are also learning as
well in terms of in terms of this it is
it is a learning curve let's do it as to
what we can't what we can do
what I think is really really important
as well is that we get the public trust
that we are doing things so uh so so to
to be fair within that just as a moment
about the Cyclops Junction that you
mentioned before
um we're undertaking two Cyclops
Junctions uh on uh on um uh on Talbot
right
um great Stone Road in terms of adding
the complexities of those into it that
date of starting of uh of late 2023 will
most definitely slip back and what we
what we want to do is to make sure that
even having these are having some of the
uh some of the delays that we've that
we've had already that we are as fast as
we can actually seeing some seeing some
real progress on the ground because
that's actually where people wanted it
from that from that initial consultation
so that that to me has been the priority
in terms of that which is one of the
driving forces behind what we've done
okay then
I mean if there's nothing else on on
this and as I say I'm not sure that what
we can actually recommend because you
know we've most of us haven't been
involved with the uh you know the whole
process
um so I'm happy for the local people to
to to to get on with it particularly now
that there seems to be some progress
being made I think that was a worry that
there wasn't being any progress made so
um I think we'll leave it at that if
everybody's happy to do that yeah okay
well thanks for that and we'll now move
on to item nine uh and that is the ex
executive response to disability access
task and finish group interim report
which is on
thank you chair I presented this report
in full to exec in July and as with
other reports this evening I'm not going
to do that again in full
um assuming you've all read the report I
just would like to draw out a few key
points uh if if I could please
um just to open with I think it's
important to recognize that the ambition
of this uh report this piece of work is
is to ensure better outcomes for
disabled people through our planning
role and I would like to reassure
scrutiny that that is the ambition very
much to of the executive
um the report I believe fairly balances
or reflects the balance that we can
secure through our planning function and
areas of design and development that sit
within building regulation over which we
have less control
it sets out in Practical terms how we
can be using more of our soft power to
secure accessible development through
early and proactive discussions with
developers and with training for
officers and counselors
I think the point I'd like to make to
committee tonight is that there is a
much bigger picture at play here which
is touched on in the report but I would
like to sort of emphasize here that in
Trafford we have a raft of planning
policy coming forward in the next 12 to
2 12 months to two years which puts
accessibility at the front of center of
our planning policy
um and and that would be our traffic
design guide and our traffic design
codes which um will come into fruition
next year
that's places for everyone which has
been a bit
um
we followed the process so far but now
he's under the process of examining that
in public is now underway and after that
process we'll come forward our local
plan which we've already done a
considerable amount of work on but in
planning in adoption terms sits behind
places for everyone and which is which
is uh the top tier of the planning
policy that we'll use I would like to
recognize the frustrations of the
planning committee because they have to
make balance planning decisions based on
policy as it exists
and clearly uh we're we're a bit away
from adopting those policies that I've
just talked you through
um but the proposals that we set out
back to the report are merely a sort of
an interim stop Gap
um that we're proposing until we have
this very robust
um planning framework in place locally
and just finally I just I don't see this
as sort of the end of this discussion in
any which way I appreciate that this
will be an ongoing issue and an ongoing
discussion
with with scrutiny and with the planning
committee and one which I'm more than
happy to to carry on engaging with thank
you
so thanks for that uh it's appreciated
the report
um I think
you you you're right in terms of the I
think this is almost a beginning
um who had a council you know that there
is a a big responsibility for public
sector equality Duty really
um that is uh enshrined in law and I
think
um
you know we have been remiss I I believe
in in the past in in terms of the
planning process where we haven't
um you know set out what we could have
set out
um you know when that
um
law came out
um but I think
it seems to me that there is a lot now
that it is
um being developed with the plumbing
committee
um and the planning process
which will certainly bear fruit and that
I think the kind of pre-planning as well
to get over you know the the fact that
we haven't got our local plan in place
yet
um could could and I think should
actually work in terms of working with
our developers
um so I'm pleased that action's been
taken I think there is
some issues around
the plumbing committee and and how we
work with the
what they call it building control
um element of it because there seems to
be two different rules between planning
and
um and the building control section
um
and you know it it's how that actually
works and
um quickly you know can that actually be
a detriment to what what the council's
trying to do I mean they are two sort of
separate regulatory roles and it's not
it's not plan building rigs aren't
something that are considered a planning
committee stage I'm happy Adrian is a an
expert in the in this field and perhaps
he could explain the different
yeah so the building regulations are are
set nationally and we have no control
over their content so it's our duty to
administer those but they're set by the
government
um there is a slight confusion that
comes in in that when
um we do have the option as a report
described
um as a planning authority to apply
um uh higher standards of accessibility
if we wish to but the way the government
has said that we need to do that is to
effectively what they is through our our
local plan and what that does is
actually gives us access to another
chapter of the building regulations so I
think this is kind of sometimes where
um it is a little confusing because
whilst they are completely separate
regimes there is a read across at that
particular point but but what we can't
do unfortunately is is through the
planning system insist on on
um kind of uh standards that otherwise
would be governed by the building
regulations because that separate
legislation and the government has
decreed effect they decrease nationally
what what needs you know what what
standards buildings are built to so so
there are you know that I think as a
report identifies there are limits into
you know what we can do
um between those two
um legislations thank you
so any comments anybody wants to make
no
yeah
um in in the report it does say that um
the conclusion is that um
foreign
team will go out of their way to
accommodate the recommendations from the
from the scrutiny committee so so I'm
happy with that but the recommendation
was achieved from the previous meeting
can I just say sort of anecdotally I'm a
member of the planning committee very
happy to be so and at every meeting we
are berate in our offices saying can we
do this can we do that pushing them on
on building rigs asking those questions
to improve access for disabled people
and rightly so it's a very hot topic and
planning and uh I know we'll be having
further meetings
um with councilor Patel on this
um so it's a very important issue for
everybody on this committee I'm sure and
certainly for the planning committee
okay well I uh I'm pleased that it you
know the the response has come back I
know there was a time lapse in in
because of the pandemic and all the
other things and
um anyway we we've got it now and I
think
um it's certainly moving in the right
direction and
um for for my thoughts is that it it is
a duty
um equality it is a duty of it all
really and uh and if we if we can make
better progress
um in the future I think that would be
very beneficial to many many people in
in the borough
so thanks for that
um we'll move on to item 10. uh the
executive response to the Gypsy Rome
Roma and travelers
um visit task and finish group interim
report
so
does anybody want to
so I mean it's there for everybody to to
see how are we
um yeah so I think thank you for the um
report I think um I'm still not really
clear about some I think I need some
more information really I feel like I'm
not clear about the costs of the current
cleanups and Council intervention to
assess whether providing toilets and
bins is a good way forward I know
residents are very very concerned by you
know human excrement in the Parks and
that kind of thing
um and also not
I'm also not clear about the negotiated
stopping policy from the report as well
I I wondered if the transit pitch is the
same as this or is it something
different it does feel that negotiator
stopping policy is probably a really
good Way Forward
so I've got rather a lot here
um I think it's where I've regarding the
police but I'm still not really clear
about that I wonder I understand that
section 177 will continue to be used
unless there's an urgent need to move on
and if there is an urgent need will
bailiates continue to be used I will
section 61 be used and if the section 61
is used
does that have implications on our
discrimination policies
um and the other thing is that it's
great that you're contacting Ward
councils but I think all councils need
to be made aware of traveler visits
because they could easily be moving on
to someone to somewhere in their walls
so I think it would be really useful if
if we're all contacted and I think I
just want a bit more clarification
really I think I need to I think we need
to revisit this with some more costings
really I know it's an interim report I
understand anyway because it's there's
other things going on but thank you
yeah I think we were informed weren't we
that
um the the
consideration particularly around
um a static site
and other matters
um
you know the executive would
um
consider all of those points in more
detail around December time
yeah
yeah
how you doing
um yeah chair I think the as regards the
um the costing Point obviously there
will be a further report we'll look at
that
um I mean just to give an indication
um it it was several thousand pounds um
in terms of the the cost of the cleanup
so so it is that kind of cost benefit
thing but obviously that's what the
report will address
as regards to the
um uh stopping point versus a Transit
um pitch um effectively they do do they
fulfill the same purpose in that they
are designed to accommodate
um groups of
um Gypsies and travelers who are passing
through the borough
what a Transit site is is is a permanent
facility so that that's one that is is
is you know set up it has you know a
whole range of facilities but
um obviously with that you need to first
of all identify a site you would
normally have to obtain planning
permission and then there's the cost of
not only construction but also ongoing
maintenance
a stopping facility is
um effectively
um a a temporary area so often it's an
area of perhaps disused or former
Highway something of that nature that
could be used
um you know as a
um you know for perhaps occasional
visits you may have you know
um a bean and a portaloo and things of
that nature so that there are some basic
facilities
um and and and I suppose the way this
works is that perhaps
um in areas where there are a lot of
visits then it there's a benefit in
having a permanent Transit site because
um you know the sort of costs of setting
it up and the cost of running it make
that worthwhile
um
um but um where you have occasional
visits then that's perhaps where a
negotiated stock Point can can come in
but but again I think some some of the
you know the detailed merits of that
we're obviously going to investigate
further yeah because I think the I'm not
really clear whether we have occasional
visits or frequent visits in Trafford
because I don't really know you know
about the the extent of the of the
visits it historically they've been
occasional
um so
um last year was a particularly busy
year
um and I think it was 12 visits but some
of our neighbors say some of our rural
neighbors
um you know I think the two Cheshire
authorities had in excess of 50
um visits each so so our visits are
um obviously with smaller geographically
but
um it it seemed like a lot and it was a
lot for Trafford
um it's probably not a lot nationally
um but certainly you know the pattern
over say the past 10 years has been for
a lot less than it was in 2021
can't cancel out that just uh briefly
chair a little bit obviously uh last
year I've covered it a lot more The
Traveler portfolio we're going to do now
but it's obviously cover it to some
extent uh obviously part of the problem
we had last year I did actually ask
about uh putting in bins and so forth
because that was automatically we knew
that that would be cost effective to put
them in the first place I think uh and
Adrian just out while I'm from the
public and we're locked up third with
things like portals in these where they
simply appear on a camp and uh
was that obviously there's only a small
number of specialist providers actually
have these usually these uh Travelers
sort of appear usually I think they're
having something on a Friday Friday
afternoon so it's actually before the
counter everywhere's all shut so it's
actually Monday morning before we can do
anything that could be assessed and so
forth and then uh that would have been a
small number of companies if it's by
ironically across uh the nature of this
thing is that they're going to be like
uh spring and during the summer at the
same time these organizations have also
handled things out to like large events
and other things community events and so
forth so you aren't necessarily going to
build up automatically get availability
and it will take time to order them and
so forth so uh whilst something we want
to look at further it's not going to be
as straightforward as you actually think
is putting them in there are
complications with them so I think it's
up that way look at that because I sent
me uh uh when I was told that we have
some of our stuff that's actually having
to clean up the mess that's left in
these temporary encampments it's I
certainly would not you know like like
Sierra staff do that sort of work so I
think nobody wants to see that so I
think if it's manageable and it's uh you
know it's something that can be examine
further in that sense of it I think just
on the point now about these uh agreed
stopping points I think that's that
would be obviously a stop Gap measure
for the next period of time so we
actually look at it in our local plans
where more sort of stronger provision
would be estimate across traffic and
across GM as well so it's actually seen
as a period where we sort of said was
turned up in the park on a Friday night
back in agreed location where it's
actually better and easier to plant to
such things as well I think thank you
okay okay yeah okay Council
thanks chair um yeah I think there's
quite a lot of good recommendations in
there that you know I think we were at
them what they they could really be
beneficial I've been looking at um the
recommendation to do the consultation
with the Gypsy Romanian controller
community and I was wondering if there's
any possibility we could develop some
sort of uh acceptable behavior contracts
within that consultation process because
many of the issues that come through
things like loud music at night which is
simply an issue University you know
we've had quite a few um
communities growing there for short
periods of time and I wonder if we could
drop some sort of contract with them
that might help
prevent the problem most people are
acceptable of them but they do get very
annoyed when there's live music late at
night and you know causing distrust to
to residents
sure then absolutely and I I think well
there are I suppose there are a couple
of issues here if it's land on which say
the council has has ownership
um then then
um in a sense this is those issues
you've described are exactly those that
perhaps come into play
um in terms of maybe whether the police
get involved in moving on in terms of
anti-social behavior and and what will
normally happen is that
um when they first arrived there'll be a
welfare assessment made so there is a
visit there's a visit early on and I
suppose the interesting thing is could
we then almost say well if you're gonna
wish to stay these are the the kind of
standards that
um you need to abide by
um we can certainly have a look to see
if that is done elsewhere because
um in relation to say the temporary
stopping place we would almost certainly
need to have some sort of
um
similar thing really in place to ensure
that if people are stopping they do
abide by certain standards of behavior
so we can perhaps incorporate that into
the report yeah I think that would that
would be a good idea because they know
you know where they stand and it will be
better from the resident's perspective
as well that could be achieved you know
it's a very short stay
okay
thank you uh I think on that point
perhaps it will be difficult to have
these kind of uh residents or other
good behavior kind of City because there
are transient communities aren't they so
how do you sort of look at that in that
respect
there is certainly lots of issues on it
I think recently berries had some real
problems you know with some communities
that have been there and created these
uh huge problems for them and Manchester
previously had the same situation so I
don't know how the other authorities are
dealing with their situations when these
happen I mean I don't know if there's
been any kind of assessment uh certainly
it uh they do
cause lots of anxiety for the local
residents particularly in the locations
where they are I mean some counselors
perhaps don't have that kind of issue
um in their Wards but I mean certainly
in the wards that they do happen it does
create a bit of a headache and yes it's
seasonal and it's uh that repeats itself
every year uh considering how much we've
been talking about the budget and how
much you know the the
um we we would lose we haven't gotten
enough money how we can fund those kind
of aspects that we're talking about in
the in order to facilitate
um that that setting
so there's a lot to really to be
considered in a way
thank you thank you
all right
anybody else know
all right well we've we've got the
report haven't we and uh you know the
the there have been some
further suggestions around how we can
communicate
um
so
um
however we will get a report in in
December as well a further report
um so
item 12 it's a work program which we've
all
got
um
Alex do you want to
just
raise raise anything within that or did
it are we just noting it uh it's the
opportunity at every meeting it was one
of the recommendations made within the
screen review that each item it would be
um
each meeting it would be a stunning item
so that counts has had the opportunity
to put into the work program and shape
over the course of the year
um so if anyone has anything they would
like to add then please put it Forward
um right is there any question to
anybody wants to ask or yes
like share not strictly what Alex is
saying but uh we canceled our Tuscan
finish group uh the other week
so I'm hoping that we're going to try
and arrange a meeting to get other
councils together Alex
um and catch up where we where we need
to be
um
yeah it was canceled because of
obviously uh
the funeral
yes it was Council new it's due to
happen last Monday
um so I'll email all the group tomorrow
and pick a date for a catch up to be
helped that would be good is there
anything else on there that anybody
wants to raise
no
okay well
I think that's actually concludes the
meeting
um
yeah urgent business I don't have any
um
so that yeah it's the meeting is closed
now and but can I thank you all very
much uh offices and executive members
and all the committee members under Alex
of course
um thank you all for your contributions
and and help and have a safe journey
home